Labels should be prominent and
visible when a user is filling
out their associated inputs.
When writing HTML, use the label
element as a container for your inputs.
Associated inputs get
nested inside labels.
You could use the for attributes
to link inputs and labels.
Either way works fine, but
I like to nest because it simplify
my HTML and makes it more semantic.
As an important bonus,
applying labels to our form elements
helps to improve the touch target size.
The user can touch either the label or
the input in order
to place the focus on the input element,
like I'm doing right now.
And you could see here that
we're using the four attributes.
Okay, enough of me talking.
I want you to try one
out in the next quiz.